ahora le propongo que hablemos con
nuestra cronista Rosa Pérez más deu
quien normalmente tiene la sección de
revista de prensa y hoy nos va a hacer
un repaso de cómo los medios
internacionales están cubriendo esta
noticia Rosa bienvenida Buenos días
María Clara Buenos días a Santiago
evidentemente Esta es una noticia que
hoy protagonista titulares
internacionales alrededor del mundo ya
sea con unos calificativos con otros
pero hemos preparado una selección de
los que hemos encontrado más
representativos
bueno Rosa contanos hablamos de América
Latina empezamos si les parece por
Europa porque es una bloque fundamental
en términos del apoyo a Ucrania no y de
la legitimidad de este apoyo frente a
las consecuencias en términos sobre todo
energéticas no que está sufriendo el
continente como consecuencia de su
posicionamiento frente a Moscú bien
empezamos con and the Times en Reino
Unido un Aliado clave para kiaz que
señala el año de sangre de Ucrania
continuamos con Liberación este medio
francés que titula un año después
Ucrania en pie En referencia a esta
Guerra Relámpago que no fue no
finalmente un año después Aquí
continuamos los swag de Bélgica titula
el año del despertar el país de España
un año de la guerra más global desde
1945 señala que la decisión de Putin de
Putin de invadir Ucrania alteró impugnó
el orden mundial y que hay 50 países que
aquellas de los que de los cuales 30 les
suministras les suministran armas y
cerramos con Público de Portugal que
dice la barbaria un año después Bueno yo
le quiero dar un breve paso a nuestro
invitado Jesús agreda bienvenido de
nuevo aquí a France 24 una breve opinión
sobre estas portadas que creen que
muestran muestran primero que todo por
supuesto una legitimación de la
resistencia ucraniana y sobre todo
muestran una necesidad decir finalmente
la idea de Europa es mantener un orden
que se había creado que de alguna forma
se asumía que garantizaba la estabilidad
en otras palabras habíamos asumido que
las instituciones y las normas
internacionales habían eliminado la
posibilidad de guerra de Europa y Rusia
demostró lo contrario y finalmente lo
que vemos es un un una resistencia
europea por evitar ese cambio y esa
transformación Y eso Y eso implica un
apoyo casi que incondicional con Rusia y
su derecho y finalmente su necesidad de
resistir los medios europeos entonces
mostrando como cambia o cómo se oponen a
que cambie este régimen existente Rosa y
en las portadas de América y en general
en el cubrimiento de los medios en
América Latina lo que considero muy
interesante es que si bien muchos países
latinoamericanos no se han posicionado
no se han alineado tan claramente con
Ucrania como si lo ha hecho Estados
Unidos o los aliados europeos en cambio
los medios latinoamericanos sí que se
han volcado con Ucrania desde el
principio de la invasión y así lo
reflejan también estas portadas en este
aniversario del inicio de la guerra
total por ejemplo o globo de Brasil
titula frente estancado un año de guerra
en Ucrania sin salida a la vista y esta
falta de perspectivas respecto al final
de este conflicto es uno de las una de
las cuestiones más destacadas en toda la
prensa por otro lado la fuera de Sao
Paulo dice la guerra en Ucrania Sella un
nuevo orden mundial el país en este caso
de Cali de aquí de Colombia dice la
guerra que asusta al mundo cumple un año
lo que parecía una fácil invasión se
convirtió en un Calvario para Rusia El
mercurio de chile señala Ucrania en
máxima por ofensiva rusa a un año del
inicio de la guerra lo que nos comentaba
Catalina desde kiev que finalmente de
momento parece que no está sucediendo
que Rusia tampoco está aprovechando este
aniversario para lanzar una mayor
ofensiva quisiera aprovechar este repaso
por medio de América Latina para hablar
con Jesús acerca de un tema que ha
estado en la agenda últimamente y que
tiene que ver precisamente con la
postura de la región de América Latina
con respecto de la guerra si bien Por
supuesto no estamos hablando de un
bloque homogéneo no hay ciertas críticas
quizás a determinado silencios
vacilaciones sobre todo con respecto a
algunos gobiernos de izquierda o
progresistas sí efectivamente A
diferencia de lo que vimos con Europa y
de los de los medios que son aliados de
Ucrania en América Latina la posición es
un poco más ambigua es decir al menos
hay apoyo pero no es un apoyo tan
significativo como lo vemos en caso
europeo lo vemos en Colombia con la
resistencia enviar armas podemos un caso
argentino igualmente y eso se debe de
alguna forma a que desde América Latina
hay algunos elementos que se comparten
con la visión rusa no En el sentido
estricto de la invasión Pero de alguna
forma algunos elementos a través de los
cuales Rusia justifica esa invasión y es
por ejemplo la idea rusa de la necesidad
de una estructura mucho más multipolar
en el sistema internacional reducir la
la hegemonía de Estados Unidos que de
alguna forma ha generado efectos
negativos no solo para la región sino
para la mayor parte del mundo y eso lo
vemos aquí decir estos gobiernos
progresistas buscan de alguna forma esa
posición similar decir de un mundo mucho
más
digamos incluyente que que los involucre
que finalmente les permite expresar su
posición y su visión del mundo ahora
Rosa Entonces ya teniendo esta postura
de cual puede ser esa posición de Rusia
precisamente los medios de este país
Cómo están cubriendo este aniversario
bien pues no encontramos referencias muy
explícitas tampoco Al aniversario de lo
que se llama en Rusia operación militar
especial Porque recordemos que está
sancionado Llamar a guerra lo que está
sucediendo en Ucrania pero hemos
señalado por ejemplo el ave domosti este
medio ruso que no tampoco un lacayo del
kremlin pero que señala como el mensaje
de Vladimir Putin del pasado martes
dio ciertas pinceladas justificando Por
qué está en marcha esta operación entre
otras cuestiones este régimen nazi de
kiev que siempre menciona Putin que es
una amenaza a largo plazo y que la
solución militar ha sido la única
después de intentar las soluciones
pacíficas a un conflicto que como dijo
Putin no le interesaba a nadie durante
años desde 2014 que estalló la guerra en
el y después del rechazo de occidente a
las apeticiones de Rusia de que no
incluyeran a Ucrania en la otan no bien
por otro lado tenemos el comer Sand que
hace un resumen de la de lo acontecido
Durante este año una un resumen que
termina con
la anexión a Rusia de las regiones de
las autoproclamadas repúblicas lugans
luego de gerson y saporilla algo que
este periódico eran regiones ucranianas
antes de esta anexión no una frase un
poco ambigua teniendo en cuenta que
Rusia reconocía la soberanía de estas
repúblicas lo hizo de hecho Putin tres
días antes de lanzar este invasión Y por
último RT titula Bueno una un titular un
poco extraño y es que Ucrania está
posicionada para invadir a la vecina
moldavia esto asegura la inteligencia
militar rusa bueno Rosa vamos ahora por
supuesto a conocer que dicen los medios
ucranianos sí los medios ucranianos hoy
dedican editoriales de una clarísima
línea bélica no de enaltecimiento
Nacional del heroicismo no de la
resistencia del pueblo de ucraniano
hemos seleccionado por ejemplo el kiev
post que dice en este sombrío
aniversario del bárbaro ataque de Rusia
contra Ucrania el post saluda a los
héroes del pueblo de este país y su
determinada resistencia unidad y firme
deseo de vivir en un estado
independiente
democrático amante de la paz y alineado
con Europa y el mundo libre y lamenta
que sea eso sí a coste de tantos
asesinados heridos desplazados por los
criminales de guerra imperialistas del
kremlin Esta es una cita literal por
supuesto de este periódico tenemos el
kefing que hace una línea del tiempo de
lo que ha sucedido también a lo largo de
estos a 12 meses de guerra Total que
termina con la visita de biden aquí eft
una clarísimo respaldo en una visita con
muchísimo simbolismo de esta importante
alianza de la otan a cualquier sin la
cual la guerra nos explicaría como la
estamos explicando a día de hoy y
terminamos con ucradina prafda que
señala como la inteligencia británica ha
descrito los cambios de estrategia de
Rusia en esta guerra en Ucrania si bien
empezó en 2014 promoviendo no los
ejércitos de las autoproclamadas
repúblicas de domíesca y lugans por otro
lado ya en 2022 intentó controlar gran
parte del territorio ucraniano y está
jugando ahora a una guerra de desgaste
Bueno ya entonces Rosa usted nos
mostraba las posturas de los medios
rusos y ucranianos y como cada uno
defiende precisamente Esa visión del
mundo que está planteando tanto Rusia
como un eje Oriental para quitarle la
hegemonía a occidente y los occidentales
intentando defender su visión de orden
mundial qué más nos tiene que decir
frente a esta posición mediática pues
hoy hay a muchísimas editoriales al
respecto de la guerra en Ucrania hemos
seleccionado una de los Mont por ejemplo
que dice una guerra dos visiones en
relación a lo que comentabas a María
Clara no de cómo está volviendo sobre la
mesa está retórica de la guerra fría con
nuevos elementos como es el
importantísimo papel a escala
internacional que juega hoy en día china
pero hemos querido plantear precisamente
esta guerra de narrativas que juega un
papel fundamental en la explicación de
lo que está sucediendo en Ucrania y es
una batalla de narrativas opuestas que
se pudo ver reflejada de forma clarísima
en la asamblea general de Naciones
Unidas del el pasado mes de septiembre
cuando intervino tanto el ministro de
exteriores de Rusia sergay labrov como
el presidente ucraniano
al mismo artículo 51 de la carta de
Naciones Unidas un artículo que recoge
el derecho a la legítima defensa
escuchemos a si les parece estas
intervenciones que dejan muy de forma
muy clara las posiciones de Moscú y de
aquí
y hemos visto Quién es el único que
quiere la guerra
la falta de decisión de los países
occidentales y la guerra continua del
régimen de kiev contra su propio pueblo
no nos dejó más opción que lanzar una
operación militar especial para proteger
a los rusos y eliminar las amenazas a
nuestra seguridad que la otan ha creado
sistemáticamente en territorio ucraniano
Ucrania ha mostrado fortaleza en el
campo de batalla utilizando su derecho a
la legítima defensa de acuerdo con el
artículo 51 de la carta de la ONU
la operación se lleva a cumplimiento de
los tratados de amistad cooperación y
asistencia mutua entre Rusia y estas
repúblicas sobre la base del artículo 51
de la carta de Naciones Unidas
bien y esta batalla no de relatos
también se vio de forma muy clara desde
el inicio de la guerra cuando tanto un
bloque como otro quisieron vetar a los
relatos digamos del enemigo
Estableciendo censuras sobre ciertos
medios de comunicación no en un mapa que
vamos a ver a continuación vemos como el
27 de febrero de 2022 la Unión Europea
vetó a los medios estatales rusos
sputnik y RT el 4 de marzo Rusia empezó
a vetar a medios occidentales entre los
cuales sienen
France 24 o distintas redes sociales
sobre todo las del grupo meta por otro
lado el 8 de mayo Estados Unidos empezó
a vetar también a televisiones rusas
alineadas con el kremlin bien y
recordamos
esta esta lógica de vetos la expresó una
personaje que ha sido central en la
propaganda rusa de esta guerra hablamos
de Margarita Simón quien es la editora
jefe de la medio Estatal ruso RT
escuchamos rápidamente sus palabras en
una tertulia televisiva en el canal
Rusia 1
ninguna gran nación puede existir Sin
Control sobre la información
y como decíamos antes siguiendo esta
línea de pensamiento Rusia impuso esta
ley que sancionó con hasta 15 años de
prisión lo que se pueda considerar
ofensas contra el ejército ruso no y una
de estas ofensas sería Llamar guerra a
lo que el kremlin califica como
operación militar especial y recordemos
que contra esta censura se viralizó una
protesta protagonizada en la televisión
en directo por Marina ofia nicoba una
periodista que ya conocimos este mes de
febrero se encuentra ya refugiada en
París la vimos reaparecer en la sede de
reporteros Sin fronteras en la capital
francesa pero recordemos este momento de
protesta en directo
recordemos que esta ley además ha
motivado el exilio o el ceso de
operaciones de muchos medios
independientes rusos como es el caso de
noaia gaceta y que por otro lado para
terminar ya con esta sección dedicada a
la batalla informativa delenski a
legitimado no que Ucrania ocupe un rol
central en la geopolítica actual también
como una campaña de comunicación que ha
dado la vuelta al mundo una campaña que
quedó muy bien definida con las palabras
del editor jefe de la revista Time
cuando justificó Por qué eligieron al
presidente ucraniano como persona del
año recordemos que estas palabras fueron
su ofensiva informativa cambió el clima
del sistema geopolítico desencadenando
una oleada de acción que sacudió al
mundo Rosa pues gracias por este
profundo repaso que nos hace y que nos
muestra cómo la guerra también se vive
en las narrativas y en los medios de
comunicación dependiendo de la postura
de las visiones del mundo que defiende
cada medio gracias